Today's country is India.
India is a big country in Asia.
India is far away and it takes about nine hours to fly there.
People in India speak a few different languages, but the main one is called Hindi.
Animals are very important in India.
Cows can walk around the road.
In India, you can also see tigers, elephants and lots of peacocks.
Peacocks are a big, beautiful bird with very special tail feathers.
They can make their feathers stand up and put on an amazing show.
India has some amazing sights to see.
This building is called the Taj Mahal.
It took 20 years to build.
Indian food is full of flavor.
It can be very sweet and very spicy.
They make and eat papadums, which are like big crisps.
India was the first country to have flushing toilets.
Indians were the first people to make buttons, shampoo...
...and they also made lots of great games like snakes and ladders and chess.
In India, they don't say hello.
Instead they say, "Namaste!"